Quoted strings, that is, strings that are surrounded by double quotes, or the like,
are a tricky issue that comes up in both JavaScript and HTML.
Let's bring all of our regular expression power to bear to see about separating
quoted strings from other words.
Here I've drawn an evil quoted string that contains a bunch of double quotes.
We really want to get to just the heart of it, just the contents and peel off
these 2 double quotes at the end.
There like the rind. I want to get to the core.
However, if I just repeatedly use string.find to look for double quotes,
I'll find this one, but also this one in the middle.
This one in the middle, and this one in the end.
So I might mistakenly think that it's 2 quoted strings--
I said, and nothing over here.
Oh no! Find isn't good enough!
In a shocking twist, we'll have to use regular expressions instead.
But first, to make our job a little easier, let me introduce to you some new regular expressions.
The first is the dot, or period, which matches any character except a new line,
or what you get when you press enter or return.
For example, here I'm looking for any decimal digit [0 - 9] and then any character--
anything except a line break--and then another [0 - 9].
So for example, this is a decimal digit. This is another decimal digit.
And the "a" between them is any character.
This 2 is a decimal digit. The 2 between them is any character. This 2 is another decimal digit.
This "cc3" doesn't qualify because this "c" is not in [0 - 9].
And one more--sometimes it's nice to be able to say anything except a digit
or anything except a number or anything except p.
Here we're looking for [0 - 9], followed by anything that's not "a" and also not "b".
So here--oh! That immediately didn't work because the next thing was an "a",
and we're asking for not "a".
Right over here we've got a 1 and a space, and space isn't "a" or "b", so that looks good.
Then here we've got a 2 and a 2, and this second 2 is not "a" or "b", so that looks good.
Here we've got a 2 and a space, and this space is not "a" or "b", so that looks good.
"C" is not [0 - 9]. "C" is not [0 - 9], 3 is [0 - 9], but then we're at the end of the string.
So that's it.